sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten orten der welt mit
das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten haben dann wurden
diese anlagen aufgegeben manche sind
heute lebensgefährlich verseucht nur ein
fernes echo hallt noch von den menschen
die hier einst lebten und arbeiteten
was bleibt sind offene fragen und
ungelöste rätsel
[Musik]
in dieser folge tauchen wir ab in die
vergangenheit auf der suche nach
antworten
was hat das größte massensterben der
geschichte mit medizinischer forschung
und dem raumfahrtprogramm zu tun
es hält sich der mythos dass der stahl
dieser schiffe in den voyager sonden
verbaut wurde die in den tiefen des alls
unterwegs sind
[Musik]
warum haben die usa im ersten weltkrieg
millionen für dampfschiffe ausgegeben um
sie dann absichtlich wieder zu versenken
um in den krieg eintreten zu können
brauchten die usa enorme
transportkapazitäten so kam es zu dem
unglaublichen auftrag tausende
holzschiffe von je 100 metern länge
bauen zu lassen
[Musik]
wir finden heraus warum der vorläufer
der modernen kriegsschiffe halb
versunken und vergessen auf der anderen
seite der welt liegt
[Musik]
in australischen gewässern liegen
insgesamt
7500 historische schiffswracks aber nur
eines stammt aus dieser faszinierende
zeit des schiffsbaus es ist weltweit das
einzige seiner art
und wir gehen an bord eines
kriegsschiffes dass während des kalten
krieges mit den sowjets katz und maus
spielte und fasst den dritten weltkrieg
auslöste
[Musik]
kaum einer weiß wie kurz wer vor einem
dritten weltkrieg standen während der
kuba-krise
[Musik]
heute zählen schiffe wie die risiken
flugzeugträger der us marine zu den
größten und komplexesten konstruktionen
der welt im verbund mit atom u booten
verleihen sie den usa große militärische
schlagkraft gegen ziele überall auf dem
globus
vor 150 jahren hat er das seinerzeit
mächtigste kriegsschiff kaum ähnlichkeit
mit den high tech giganten heutiger tage
trotzdem war es voll gepackt mit der
modernsten technik seiner zeit als es
vom stapel gelassen wurde änderte dass
die kriegsführung auf see für immer
im flachen wasser der australischen
hafen liegt eines der bedeutendsten
kriegsschiffe der weltgeschichte
das war kostet heute als wellenbrecher
vor sich hin einstmals galt es als
technologie wunder und krone de
ingenieurskunst
in australischen gewässern liegen 7500
historische schiffswracks aber nur eines
davon ist vom typ monate in brest work
monitor und stammt aus dieser
faszinierenden zeit des schiffsbaus es
ist weltweit das einzige seiner art
[Musik]
bei ihrem heutigen anblick fällt es
schwer zu glauben dass die service 1 das
fortschrittlichste schiff ihrer zeit war
was macht die zerberus so einzigartig
[Musik]
der historiker tim smith ist leiter des
amts für denkmalpflege im australischen
bundesstaat victoria er kennt die ganze
geschichte des schiffes
die zerberus wurde 1870 fertig gestellt
und kam dann hier in australien an sie
war brandneu gerade erst vom stapel
gelaufen und die fahrt nach australien
war ihre jungfernfahrt die seinerzeit
längste für ein schiff dieser art
[Musik]
mitte des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
wurden holz kriegsschiffe nach und nach
durch panzer schiffe wie die sms moria
ersetzt doch trotz ihrer eisernen
panzerung war die bauweise dieser
schiffe macht die gleiche wie vor
jahrhunderten
schließlich veränderte eine
entscheidende erfindung grundlegend die
konstruktion von kriegsschiffen und die
kriegsführung auf see im krimkrieg baute
der britische marineoffizier körper
kohls erstmals eine panzerung für
schiffs geschütze sie wurde auf einem
drehbaren untersatz montiert so dass die
kanonen in andere richtungen feiern
konnten der panzer turm war geboren das
war eine revolutionäre ära für den bau
von schlachtschiffen denn diese bauweise
mit ihr einen geschützturm vorn und
hinten blieb danach über jahrzehnte
unverändert
[Musik]
der australische bundesstaat victoria
hatte den bau des neuen schiffs typus
entscheidend vorangetrieben er hatte
einen teil des geldes für den bau des
schiffes bei seinen bürgern eingesammelt
um gegen eine drohende invasion
russlands gewappnet zu sein
[Musik]
die bewohner victorias wollten ein
schlagkräftiges kriegsschiff um die
einnahme der hafenstadt melbourne zu
verhindern in großbritannien begann
daraufhin die arbeit an einem neuen
schiffstyp es namens westwerk monitor
das schiff hatte 2 200 tonnen schwere
panzer türme mit 4 25 cm vorderladern
und einer bis zu drei zentimeter dicken
panzerung
die regierung von victoria gab das
schiff in auftrag um den hafen von
melbourne zu verteidigen die arbeiten
begannen 1867
1870 wurde das schiff in dienst gestellt
und früher nach australien das war
damals die längste reise für diesen
neuen schiffs typus eine beachtliche
leistung denn die passage war
abenteuerlich
die 3000 tonnen schwere zerbe rust wurde
nach dem schrecklichen dreiköpfigen
höllenhund benannt der in der
griechischen mythologie den eingang zur
unterwelt bewachte
vor ihr lagen nun gut 16.000 kilometer
von großbritannien bis in ihre neue
heimat australien
in melbourne angekommen erlebte die
cirrus letztlich nur friedenszeiten die
russen tauchten niemals auf und die
geschütze des monitor wurden nicht
einmal im kampf abgefeuert
ihrer zeit war die zerberus eines der
schlagkräftigsten kriegsschiffe
überhaupt sie hätte es mit jedem anderen
schiff aufnehmen können zwar musste sie
letztlich nicht einen schuss abgeben
denn die technik schritt rasant voran
und die bauweise von kriegsschiffen
veränderte sich innerhalb weniger
jahrzehnte grundlegend aber all das wäre
nicht möglich gewesen ohne die
revolutionäre technologie der zerberus
nicht ohne die planung und die
ingenieursleistung die da drin steckte
sie war eine wegbereiterin der
schlachtschiffe des ersten weltkriegs
[Musik]
als der erste weltkrieg zu ende war gab
es keine verwendung mehr für die zebus
aber was tun mit 3000 tonnen stahl und
eisen aus einer anderen epoche
die zerberus war jahrelang im hafen von
melbourne eingemottet das war ihr glück
und sicherte ihr überleben dann entstand
die idee sie als wellenbrecher zum
schutz vor küsten erosion zu versenken
so wurde die verteidigerin des hafens
zur verteidigerin der küste
[Musik]
scapa flow auf dem ordne highlands ist
einer der größten natur häfen der welt
während des ersten weltkriegs lagen hier
mehr nachfolgemodelle der zeit porös
verankern als irgendwo sonst
scapa war während der weltkriege der
hauptstützpunkt von großbritanniens
gefürchtete grond flieht der großen
flotte
[Musik]
kriege waren schon immer antrieb für
technologischen fortschritt
im frühen zwanzigsten jahrhundert wurden
viele innovationen in einem einzigen
waffen system vereint den
schlachtschiffen
[Musik]
um 1900 herum waren schlachtschiffe in
vielerlei hinsicht der inbegriff von
erfolg und fortschritt die riesigen
schiffe wurden erstmals mit dampf
turbinen angetrieben
sie hatten die modernsten
kommunikationsmitteln die besten
fernrohre die größte feuerkraft und
schiere größe der geschütze all das war
in diesen beeindruckenden schiffen
vereint den statussymbolen der marine
wer kein panzer vater zählte nicht
während des ersten weltkriegs was körper
der hauptstützpunkt der britischen
flotte
als der krieg im november 1918 zu ende
ging wurde die kaiserliche hochseeflotte
dort interniert
emily taten ist doch meisterinnen scapa
flow und weiß welches schicksal die
einstmals gefürchteten deutschen schiffe
hier ereilte
scapa flow ist von den südlichen ordne
inseln umgeben dadurch entsteht dieser
riesige naturhafen hier hinter mir und
um uns herum im ersten und im zweiten
weltkrieg war hier der strategisch beste
hafen für die britische flotte das
körper flow ende des ersten weltkriegs
auch für deutschlands flotte zum hafen
werden würde hatte dort sicher niemand
geplant aber ein großteil der
kaiserlichen marine fand hier seine
letzte ruhestätte
[Musik]
mehr als sechs monate lang hatten die
deutschen schiffe im schatten britischer
geschütze während die
friedensverhandlungen von wasser in
vollem gange waren am 21 juni 1919 nahm
kontakt miral vom euter das schicksal
der deutschen schiffe schließlich selbst
in die hand
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der untergang der kaiserlichen
hochseeflotte war die grösste
selbstversenkung der geschichte
52 schiffe sanken auf dem grund von
scapa flow von modernsten 27.000 tonnen
schlacht kreuzern bis hin zu 600 tonnen
zerstörer
[Musik]
michael james ist kapitän und
bergungsexperten
[Musik]
alle motor schiffe haben einen
sogenannten see kasten der im
maschinenraum untergebracht ist
dort wird wasser für die kühlung der
haupt- und hilfs maschinen angesaugt und
auch um die ballasttanks des schiffs zu
fluten
die entsprechenden rohre sind riesig am
haupt einlass des see kastens ist ja
durchmesser so groß dass man nicht mal
seine arme darum legen könnte
wenn man ein schiff versenken will
öffnet man einfach die ventile des
kastens und andere ventile im
maschinenraum also das wasser einströmt
bis die schwimmfähigkeit soweit
beeinträchtigt ist dass das schiff sinkt
ein mann war jedoch entschlossen die
über 400.000 tonnen stahl vom
meeresgrund zu heben
ernest cox war ein ingenieur ohne jede
erfahrung mit schiffs bergungen doch
1920 wagte er das unmögliche
in der ingenieurswissenschaft geht es im
prinzip um problemlösungen ernest cox
problem war folgendes wie kann ich 52
versenkte kriegsschiffe vom meeresgrund
heben und an land bringen kriegsschiffe
aller art und aller größen bis hin zur
schlacht kreuzern die 26.000 tonnen
wiegen
damals gab es ja noch nicht die riesigen
bergungs kräne die wir heute haben
deshalb nutzte man luft
wenn der schiffskörper wasserdicht ist
und man luft hineingepumpt ist es
möglich das schiff wieder an die
oberfläche zu bekommen das schiff muss
aber noch einigermaßen intakt sein
cox verwendete teile kleine rabe als
gewordener schiffe um damit die größeren
an die oberfläche zu heben
[Musik]
ernes cox war genial er nutzte zum
beispiel die kessel bereits gebauten
schiffe um sie zu gigantischen rohren
zusammenzuschweißen
[Musik]
diese enormen luftschleuse reichten von
der wasseroberfläche bis hinunter zu
meeresgrund wo die versenkten schiffe
lagen und durch diese rohre pumpte er
dann die luft
[Musik]
in den 20er und 30er jahren lohnte sich
die bergung der versenkten deutschen
schiffe allein wegen ihres schrott
wertes
doch 1945 als die erste atombombe
gezündet wurde fanden die überreste der
hochseeflotte eine neue bestimmung
es ist schon eine merkwürdige und
unerwartete wendung der geschichte
früher wurden panzerplatten genutzt um
die einstigen superwaffen die
schlachtschiffe vor der gewaltigsten
feuerkraft ihrer zeit zu schützen und
jetzt verwendete man sie um die
effektivität der neuesten generation von
superwaffen zu analysieren die atombombe
stahl der vor den ersten atombombentest
hergestellt wurde weist wesentlich
niedrigere strahlungswerte auf als
heutiger stahl denn bei der herstellung
von güte stahl werden große mengen luft
angesaugt die heutzutage leicht
radioaktiv ist
wenn man aber strahlung misst kann man
keine geräte brauchen die selbst schon
strahlen stahl der seit 1919 auf dem
meeresgrund gelegen hatte ist also ideal
auch in der medizin benötigte man um
verstrahlte instrumente um
strahlenbelastungen im menschlichen
körper zu messen
[Musik]
auf der anderen seite des atlantiks
nicht weit von washington dc liegt maze
nur
wenige meter unter der wasseroberfläche
liegen hier die überreste einer weiteren
geister flotte aus dem ersten weltkrieg
der potomac ist einer der
geschichtsträchtigsten flüsse in den usa
und einer der wichtigsten wasserstraßen
nach washington dc doch kaum einer weiß
dass in einem seiner seiten arme wie
zeugnisse eines irrwitzigen plans liegen
der die usa millionen von dollar kostete
der schiffsfriedhof von
50 km südlich von washington dc auf dem
potomac river die kleine bucht ist etwa
einen kilometer breit und randvoll mit
holz dampfschiffen aus dem ersten
weltkrieg alles in allem liegen hier
rund 130 schiffe 100 davon stammen aus
dem ersten weltkrieg
als die usa im april 1917 in den ersten
weltkrieg eintraten produzierten sie
schon seit zwei jahren rüstungsgüter für
die alliierten doch nun galt es die
eigenen truppen auszurüsten
als die usa in den krieg ein traten
mussten sie nicht mehr nur die
alliierten weiter versorgen sondern auch
ihre eigenen männer über schaffen dazu
brauchten sie transportkapazität aber
die gab es nicht so kam es zu dem
ungewöhnlichen auftrag 1000 je 100 meter
lange holz schiffe zu bauen
es war eines der größten schiffs
bauprojekte aller zeiten
unterwasserarchäologen so längle hat die
geschichte dieses mammutprojekt
erforscht
als die usa an den ersten weltkrieg
eintraten kam der kühne plan auf
innerhalb von 18 monaten rund zwei
millionen tonnen transportkapazität zu
schaffen dafür sollten 1000 dampfschiffe
gebaut werden keine militärischen
schiffe sondern zivile
versorgungsschiffe
das problem war nur dass die fast 100
meter langen schiffe höchstens zehn
knoten schnell waren also ziemlich
langsam und dadurch leicht angreifbar
aber sie waren auch entbehrlich
angesichts der gefahr durch u-boote war
das kalkül lieber schnell gebaute
holzschiffe verlieren als teure panzer
schiffe hauptsache der nachschub für die
alliierten in europa reißt nicht ab
die starke sein und die großen werften
in den usa waren sowieso voll
ausgelastet
1000 neue dampfschiffe aus stahl zu
bauen war illusorisch
der us regierung blieb also nichts
anderes übrig als auf die bautechnik
vergangener epochen zurückzugreifen
[Musik]
1916 war der stahl schiffbau in den usa
noch keine entwickelter industriezweig
also besann man sich auf die
handwerklichen traditionen und baute mit
holz
dampfmaschinen in holzschiffe einzubauen
und das war schneller als er ist neuer
werften zu bauen
der auftrag für den bau dieser
gigantischen holzschiff lotte ging an 87
verschiedene werften im ganzen land das
projekt sollte der us bauindustrie zu
neuer größe verhelfen um den krieg
entscheiden doch schon mal zeigte sich
dass die werften mit der aufgabe heillos
überfordert waren
umbauten und verbesserungen an den
schiffen trieben zudem die kosten in
astronomische höhen
am ende kostete jedes schiff eine
million dollar auch der zeitplan konnte
nicht eingehalten werden anders lief
außer kontrolle doch erstaunlicherweise
beendete die us regierung das projekt
erst knapp ein jahr nach kriegsende
doch was tun mit den mehr als 200
nutzlosen schiffen die jeden monat
tausende dollar unterhalt kosteten es
gab nur eine option
die mehrzahl der schiffe lag im fluss
vor anker in der nähe von world water
dann wurden sie nach alexandria
geschleppt um das metall auszuschlachten
manchmal auch das holz aber meistens nur
das metall aber immer wieder gab es
probleme bei sturm rissen sich schiffe
los trieben ab und wurden zu einer
gefahr für die schifffahrt schließlich
wurden die boote verteilt bis auf höhe
der wasserlinie abgebrannt in die bucht
geschleppt und mit steinen beschwert
fälle im wasser verhinderten dass sie
abtreiben beim größten feuer wurden 30
schiffe gleichzeitig abgebrannt
[Musik]
1000 holzschiffe zum stückpreis von
einer million dollar ist das jetzt das
typisch amerikanische wir schaffen das
oder wir hätten es lieber lassen sollen
heute bilden die schiffe ein künstliches
ökosystem das teuerste naturschutzgebiet
aller zeiten
balance bay ist heute der größte
schiffsfriedhof der westlichen
hemisphäre ein einzigartiges biotop mit
großer artenvielfalt
eine der größten pleiten der us
geschichte hat letztlich doch noch ein
versöhnliches ende gefunden
[Musik]
auch die südenglische stadt rochester
hat ein entsorgungsproblem
[Musik]
in dem fall geht es um ein sowjetisches
kriegsschiff das vor 50 jahren fast den
dritten weltkrieg ausgelöst hätte
[Musik]
der mit wave fluss war über jahrhunderte
die heimat der britischen royal navy
kriegsschiffe sind in rochester ein
gewohnter anblick
überrascht war man hier trotzdem als im
jahr 2003 ein ehemaliges sowjetisches
b49 u-boot auftauchte
john's hatten ist verantwortlich für das
relikt des kalten krieges
[Musik]
dies ist der router torraum der b 49 und
das ist einer von 22 torpedos die das
boot mit führen konnte sie hatten
meistens konventionelle sprengköpfe
konnten aber auch mit
nuklearsprengköpfen ausgerüstet werden
das war aber nicht immer der fall
[Musik]
viele glauben der kalte krieg sei ein
eher abstrakter konflikt gewesen in der
beide seiten mit ihren sieben rasselten
aber dabei auf abstand bleiben
doch auch sie kam es mehrmals zu
direkten konfrontationen
u boote entwickelten sich zur
schlagkräftigsten waffe der sowjet
flotte doch während die us marine und
die briten auf atomgetriebene u boote
setzten nutzte die udssr weiterhin auch
konventionelle diesel elektrische boote
wie die b49
die sowjets hielten sich bei ihren
u-booten an das motto nichts reparieren
was nicht kaputt ist
sie hielten an der dieseltechnologie
fest weil sie funktionierte die boote
konnten überall hinfahren wenn auch
nicht gerade mit dem größten komfort
im maschinenraum liefen drei riesige
eisenbahn dieselmotoren rund um die uhr
es herrschte eine fürchterliche enge
lärm und gestank müssen unerträglich
gewesen sein
[Musik]
das größte problem der konventionellen
diesel u boote war dass sie nicht lange
unter wasser bleiben konnten
die foxtrott klasse konnte etwa zwei
tage unter wasser bleiben vielleicht
auch drei aber dann kann man die
batterien schon an ihre grenzen sie
konnten auf schnorchel tiefe gehen und
bei laufenden motoren die batterien
aufladen
aber dann waren sie vom flugzeug aus
leicht zu sehen weil sie nur etwa vier
meter unter der wasseroberfläche lagen
diese schwachstelle der foxtrott klasse
wurde besonders deutlich als vier
u-boote während der kubakrise kurs auf
kuba namen
die während der kubakrise in der karibik
eingesetzten sowjet gehörten zur
foxtrott lasse die amerikaner entdeckten
damals nicht alle u boote während ihrer
fahrt durch den atlantik nur zwei die
sie zum auftauchen zahlen sie warteten
einfach über ihnen bis ihnen die luft
ausging aber die anderen beiden kamen
irgendwie durch
die zustände an bord der sowjetischen u
boote müssen alles andere als angenehm
gewesen sein
[Musik]
die russen hatten die u-boote als
kriegsgerät konzipiert das waren keine
ausflugsdampfer auf denen man sich
erholen sollte
hitze gestank und feuchtigkeit müssen
unerträglich gewesen sein je nach ozean
nicht angenehm klassen des spielens an
bord herrschte eine klaustrophobische
enge es gab eine toilette und zwei
duschen für 74 männer man kann sich
vorstellen wie ekelhaft das nach ein
paar tagen war es ist mir ein rätsel wie
sie diese langen fahrten überhaupt
überstanden haben
was die us streitkräfte nicht wussten
die sowjetischen u boote hatten torpedos
mit nuklearsprengköpfen an bord ein
sowjetischer kommandant der keinen
kontakt nach moskau hatte und nicht
wusste ob der krieg schon ausgebrochen
war hatte den finger bereits auf dem
abschuss knopf
die wenigsten wissen wie kurz wir vor
einem dritten weltkrieg standen während
der kubakrise die
us flieger warfen wasserbomben auf die
sowjetischen u boote und da waren die
schon lange unter wasser
und eines der boote hatte einen
kommandanten der seine nerven nicht mehr
im griff hatte
sie hatten den befehl funkstille mit
russland zu halten und wussten
dementsprechend nicht was los war aber
sie wussten durch abgefangene
funksprüche das an der oberfläche
einiges los war und man nach ihnen
suchte und ein kapitän war ziemlich
schießwütig und kurz davor einen nuklear
torpedo abzufeuern
er war schon viel zu lange unter wasser
er dachte der dritte weltkrieg sei
ausgebrochen und wollte auf den knopf
drücken und einen torpedo mit
atomsprengkopf auf die us-marine
abfeuern aber sein kamerad sagte nein
stopp das kannst du nicht machen wenn es
jemals einen vergessenen helden gegeben
hat dann diesen mann der seinen
kommandanten davon abgehalten hatte den
dritten weltkrieg auszulösen
[Musik]
nach dem zusammenbruch der sowjetunion
und des warschauer pakts waren die
abwrack werften rund um den erdball
plötzlich voll mit ausrangierten
kriegsschiffen
daraus entstand eine ganz neue bedrohung
[Musik]
vor allem verrosten de atom u boote sind
tickende zeitbomben
aber auch konventionelle diesel u boote
sind voller tödlicher giftstoffe
sie wie früher einfach im meer zu
versenken kommt nicht in frage
vor allem die sowjetischen u boote waren
ohnehin schon gefährlich für die umwelt
[Musik]
obwohl das u boot wie 49 einen
schrottreifen eindruck macht lässt sein
heutiger besitzer es restaurieren
er will daraus eine touristenattraktion
machen
der schiffsfriedhof von crosby ist schon
heute eine einzigartige kombination aus
archäologischer stätten
naturreservat und naherholungsgebiet
aber die vor 100 jahren eigentlich
zusammengezimmerten schiffe werden nicht
ewig halten
[Musik]
balance bay gehört sicher zu den
beliebtesten historischen stätten und
naturschutzgebieten
die schiffe erzählen eine geschichte
auch über die rolle der handelsmarine
und jetzt sind sie anteil der umwelt und
verkörpern ökologische und historische
aspekte gleichermaßen - bay wird auch in
zukunft ein lebendiges umweltlabor sein
[Musik]
die zarges wird wohl keine
touristenattraktion mehr werden ihr
wrack dient heute der forschung und dem
küstenschutz
[Musik]
wir erforschen das fragt nun schon seit
jahrzehnten mit
archäologischen untersuchungen versuchen
wir seine geschichte stück für stück zu
rekonstruieren
wir untersuchen das äußere und auch das
innere des schiffs zum teil auch mit
ferngesteuerten robotern
und jedes mal lernen wir mehr über die
konstruktion des schiffs über seine
ausstattung und den rumpf mit seinem
niedrigen tiefgang über die technik der
geschütze und die panzerung von so einem
einzigartigen schiff kann man viel
lernen
die sieben verbliebenen wracks der
deutschen hochseeflotte die in scapa
flow auf grund liegen ziehen heute
sporttaucher aus aller welt an und es
kursieren gerüchte wonach sich der stahl
der schwesterschiffe auf einer
unglaublichen letzten reise befindet
es hält sich der mythos dass stahl
dieser versunkenen deutschen
schlachtschiffe in den voyager sonden
verbaut wurde die in den tiefen des alls
unterwegs sind
die vorstellung dass ein teil der
deutschen hochseeflotte am rand des
sonnensystems unterwegs ist klingt
bizarr aber das veraltete technik einer
neuen bestimmung zugeführt wird ist
nicht ungewöhnlich es wäre nicht das
erste mal dass schiffs panzerungen
genutzt wurden um ins weltall
vorzudringen
[Musik]
mythos oder nicht den deutschen
konstrukteuren die diese schiffe vor
langer zeit bauten dürfte die
vorstellung gefallen haben dass ihre
arbeit zu intergalaktischen ehren
gekommen ist auf ihrer reise durch das
weltall